puis j'en parlais beaucoup avec le papa
de justin mais dans les années soixante
dix et monsieur trudeau vous pourrez
jamais arrêter ça et j'avais raison ça
jamais arrêté mais au lieu que les
jeunes aillent à notre police qui nous
regardent acheter ça dans l'ue elle
rendit la pharmacie au bureau de tabac
vous allez faire un argent fou avec ça
avec un petit thème dessus commerce avec
le mexique échanges formidables et il y
aura pas de strychnine là dedans il y
aura pas toutes les cochonneries
chimiques qu'on peut trouver ça va être
contrôlé et évidemment ce qu'on appelle
la diction mental comme il ya un
alcoolique sur dix bénévoles qui sont
irrécupérables
on va peut-être la voie pour ça des gens
qui vont aller vers les drogues dures
vers les drogues chimiques qu'on appelle
ça ecstasy lsd à l'époque et la morphine
sauce on parle pas de cela l'on parle de
l'herbe
ok c'est bien clair et donc je lui
disais ça va être comme en suède le jour
où ils ont légalisé les films porno ça à
ton but seul bon et là le fait que ce
soit interdit tous les jeunes ados qui
sont un peu rebelle ça ça augmente le
plaisir